The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Today we're going to finish
up with Markov chains.
And the last topic will be
dynamic programming.
I'm not going to say an awful
lot about dynamic programming.
It's a topic that was enormously
important in
research for probably 20
years from 1960 until
about 1980, or 1990.
And it seemed as if half the
Ph.D. theses done in the
control area and the
operations research
were in this area.
Suddenly, everything seemed
to be done, could be done.
And strangely enough, not
many people seem to
know about it anymore.
It's an enormously useful
algorithm for solving an awful
lot of different problems.
It's quite a simple algorithm.
You don't need the full power
of Markov chains in order to
understand it.
So I do want to at least talk
about it a little bit.
And we will use what we've done
so far with Markov chains
in order to understand it.
I want to start out today by
reviewing a little bit of what
we did last time about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
This was a somewhat awkward
topic to talk about, because
you people have very different
backgrounds in linear algebra.
Some of you have a very strong
background, some of you have
almost no background.
So it was a lot of material for
those of you who know very
little about linear algebra.
And probably somewhat boring
for those of you
use it all the time.
At any rate, if you don't know
anything about it, linear
algebra is a topic that you
ought to understand for almost
anything you do.
If you've gotten to this point
without having to study it,
it's very strange.
So you should probably take
some extra time out, not
because you need it so
much for this course.
We won't use it enormously
in many of the
things we do later.
But you will use it so many
times in the future that you
ought to just sit down, not to
learn abstract linear algebra,
which is very useful also, but
just to learn how to use the
topic of solving linear
equations.
Being able to express them
in terms of matrices.
Being able to use the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
and matrices as a way of
understanding these things.
So I want to say a little more
about that today, which is why
I've called this a review
plus of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors.
It's a review of the topics
we did last time, but it's
looking at it in a somewhat
different way.
So let's proceed with that.
We said that the determinant of
an M by M matrix is given
by this strange formula.
The determinant of a is the sum
over all permutations of
the integers 1 to M of the
product from i equals 1 to M
of the matrix element
a sub i mu of i.
Mu of i is the permutation of
the number i. i is between one
and M, and mu of i is a
permutation of that.
Now if you look at the matrix,
which has the form, which is
block upper diagonal.
In other words, there's a matrix
here, a square matrix a
sub t, which is a transient
matrix.
There's a recurrent matrix here,
and there's some way of
getting from the transient
states to
the recurring states.
And this is the general form
that a unit chain has to have.
There are a bunch of transient
states, there are a bunch of
recurring states.
And the interesting thing here
is that the determinant of a
is exactly the determinant
of a sub t times the
determinant a sub r.
I'm calling this a instead of
the transition matrix p
because I want to replace a by
p minus lambda i, so I can
talk about the eigenvalues
of p.
So when I do that replacement
here, if I know that the
determinant of a is this product
of determinants, then
the determinant of p minus
lambda i is the determinant of
pt minus lambda it, where it is
just a crazy way of saying
a diagonal matrix.
A diagonal t by t matrix,
because this is a t by t
matrix, also.
i sub r is an r by r matrix,
where this is a square r by r
matrix also.
Now, why is it that this
determinant is equal to this
product of determinants here?
Well, before explaining why this
is true, why do you care?
Well, because we know that if
we have a recurring matrix
here, we know that it has--
I mean, we know a great
deal about it.
We know that any square matrix,
r by r matrix has r
different eigenvalues.
Some of them might be repeated,
but they're always r
eigenvalues.
This matrix here has
t eigenvalues.
OK.
This matrix here, we know has
r plus t eigenvalues.
You look at this formula here
and you say aha, I can take
all the eigenvalues here, add
them to all the eigenvalues
here, and I have every one
of the eigenvalues here.
In other words, if I want to
find all of the eigenvalues of
p, all I have to do is define
the eigenvalues of p sub t,
add them to the eigenvalues of
p sub r, and I'm all done.
So that really has simplified
things a good deal.
And it also really says
explicitly that if you
understand how to deal with
recurrent Markov chains, you
really know everything.
Well, you also have to know how
to deal with a transient
chain, but the main part of it
is dealing with this chain.
This has little r different
eigenvalues, and all of those
are eigenvalues, excuse me,
p sub r has little r
eigenvalues.
They're given by the roots
of this determinant here.
And all of those
are roots here.
OK, so why is this true?
Well, the reason for it is that
this product up here,
look at this.
We're taking the sum over
all permutations.
But which one of those
permutations can be non-zero?
If I start out by saying that a
sub t is t by t, then I know
that this might be anything.
These have to be zeroes here.
If I choose some permutation of
down here, of sum i, which
is greater than t.
In other words, if I choose
mu o i to be some
element over here.
If I choose mu of i to be less
than our equal to t, and i to
be greater than t,
what happens?
I get a term which
is equal to zero.
That term in this
product is zero.
And none of those products
can be zero.
So the only way I can get non
zeros here is when I'm dealing
with an i which is less
than or equal to t.
Namely an i here.
I have to choose a mu of
i, a column which is
less than t, also.
If I'm dealing with an i which
is greater than t, namely and
i up here, then, well, it
looks like I can choose
anything there.
But look.
I've already used up all of
these columns here by the five
by the non-zero terms here.
So I can't do anything
but use a smaller i,
smaller than t up here.
So when I look at the
permutations that are non
zero, the only permutations that
are non zero are those
where mu of i is less than t if
i less than t, and mu of i
is less than or equal to t if i
is less than or equal to t.
And mu of i is greater than
t if i is greater than t.
Now, how does that show that
this is equal here?
Well, let's look at
that a little bit.
I didn't even try to do it on
the slide because the notation
is kind of horrifying.
But let's try to write this
the following way.
Determinant of a is equal to the
sum, and now I'll write it
as a sum over mu of 1 up to t.
And the sum over mu of t
plus 1 up to, well, t
plus r, let's say.
OK, so here I have all of
the permutations of the
numbers 1 to t.
And here I have all the
permutations of the
numbers t plus 1 up.
And for all of those,
I'm going to
ignore this plus minus.
You can sort that out
for yourselves.
And then I have a product
from i equals 1 to t.
And then a product from i
equals t plus 1 up to m.
Excuse me.
i sub i, mu of i times
product of a of i.
Mu of i for i equals t plus
1 up to t plus r.
OK?
So I'm separating this product
here into a product first of
the terms i less than or equal
to t, and then for the terms i
greater than t.
For every permutation I choose
using the i's that are less
than or equal to t, I can choose
any of the permutation
using mu of i greater than
t that I choose to use.
So this breaks up in this way.
I have this sum, I
have this sum.
I have these two products, so
I can break this up as a sum
over mu of 1 to t of plus minus
product from i equals 1
to t of ai, mu of i times the
sum over mu of t plus 1 up to
t plus r ai mu of i.
Product.
OK.
So I've separated that into
two different terms.
STUDENT: T equals [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What?
STUDENT: T plus r
equals big m?
PROFESSOR: T plus
r is big m, yes.
Because I have t terms here,
and I have r terms here.
OK, so the interesting thing
here is having this non-zero
term here doesn't make
any difference here.
I mean, this is more
straightforward if you have a
block diagonal matrix.
It's clear that the eigenvalues
of a block
diagonal matrix are going to be
the eigenvalues of 1 plus
the eigenvalues of the other.
Here we have the eigenvalues
of this, and the
eigenvalues is this.
And what's surprising is that as
far as the eigenvalues are
concerned, this has nothing
whatsoever to do with it.
OK.
The only thing that this has
to do with it is it says
something about the sums of this
matrix here, because the
sums of these rows are
now less than 1.
They all have to be, some of
them, at least, have to be
less than or equal to 1.
Because you do have this way of
getting from the transient
elements to the non transient
elements.
But it's very surprising that
these elements, which are
critically important, because
those are the things that get
you from the transition states
to the recurrent states have
nothing to do in the eigenvalues
whatsoever.
I don't know why.
I can't give you any insights
about that, but
that's the way it is.
That's an interesting thing,
because if you take this
transition matrix, and you keep
at and a sub r fixed, and
you play any kind of funny game
you want to with those
terms going from the transient
states to the non transient
states, it won't change
any eigenvalues.
Don't know why it doesn't.
OK, so where do we
go with that?
Well, that's what it says.
The eigenvalues of p, or the t
eigenvalues of pt, and the r
eigenvalues of PR.
It also tells you something
about simple eigenvalues, and
these crazy eigenvalues, which
don't have enough eigenvectors
to go along with them.
Because it tells you that a
piece of r has all of its
eigenvectors, and a piece of t
has all of its eigenvectors.
Then you don't have any of this
crazy [INAUDIBLE] form
thing, or anything.
OK If pi is a left eigenvector
of this recurrent matrix, then
if you look at the vector,
starting was zeros, and then I
guess I should really say, well,
if pi sub 1 up to pi sub
r as a left eigenvalue of this r
by r matrix, then if I start
out with t zeroes, and then
put in pi 1 to pi r, this
vector here has to be a left
eigenvector of all of p.
Why is that?
Well, if I look at a vector,
which starts out with zeroes,
and then has this eigenvector
pi, and I multiply that vector
by this matrix here, I'm
taking these terms,
multiplying them by the columns
of this matrix, these
zeros knock out all of
these elements here.
These zeroes knock out all
of these elements.
So I start out with zeroes
everywhere here.
That's what this says.
And then when I'm dealing with
this part of the matrix, the
zeros knock out all of this, and
I just have pi multiplying
piece of r.
So if I have an eigenvalue
lambda, it says I have the
eigenvalue lambda times a
vector zero times pi.
It says that if I have an
eigenvector, a left
eigenvector of this recurrent
matrix, then that turns into,
if you put some zeroes up in
front of, it turns into an
eigenvector of the
whole matrix.
If we look at the eigenvalue 1,
which is the most important
thing this, is the thing that
gives you the steady state
factor, this is sort
of obvious.
Because the steady state
vector is where you go
eventually, and eventually where
you go is you have to be
in one of these recurrent
states, eventually.
And the probabilities within
the recurrent set of states
are the same as the
probabilities if you didn't
have this transient
states at all.
so this is all sort of obvious,
as far as the steady
state factor pi.
But it's a little less obvious
as far as the other vectors.
The left eigenvectors,
a piece of t, I don't
understand them at all.
They aren't the same as the left
eigenvectors of, well,
the left eigenvectors of the
eigenvalues of p sub t.
I didn't say this right here.
The left eigenvectors of p
corresponding to the left
eigenvectors of p sub t.
I don't understand how they
work, and I don't understand
anything you can derive
from them.
They're just kind of crazy
things, which are what they
happen to be.
And I don't care about them.
I don't know anything
to do with them.
But these other eigenvectors
are very useful.
OK.
We can extend this to as many
different recurrent sets of
states as you choose.
Here I'm doing it with a Markov
chain, which has two
different sets of recurrent
states.
They might be periodic, they
might be ergodic, it doesn't
make any difference.
So the matrix p has these
transient states up here.
Here we have those transition
states would just go to each
other, where the transition
probabilities starting with
the transient state and going
to a transition state.
Here we have the transitions,
which go from transient states
to this first set of
recurrent states.
Here we have the transitions,
which go from a transient
state to the second state
of recurrent states.
OK.
The same way as before, the
determinant of this whole
thing here, and this
determinant, the roots of that
are in fact the eigenvalues of
p, are the product of the
determinant of pt minus lambda
it times the product of this,
times this determinant here.
This has little t eigenvalues.
This has little r eigenvalues.
This has little r prime
eigenvalues, and if you add up
t plus little r plus little
r prime, what do you get?
You get jM, excuse me, capital
M, which is the total number
of states in the Markov chain.
So the eigenvalues here are
exactly the eigenvalues here
plus the eigenvalues here, plus
the eigenvalues here.
And you can find the
eigenvectors, the left
eigenvectors for these
states in exactly
the same way as before.
OK.
Yeah?
STUDENT: So again, the
eigenvalues can be repeated
both within t, r, r prime,
and in between the--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
STUDENT: There's nothing
that says [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
There's nothing that says they
can't, except you can always
find the left eigenvectors,
anyway, of this are, in fact,
these things in the form.
If pi is a left eigenvector of p
sub r, then zero followed by
pi followed by zero.
In other words, little t zeros
followed by r, followed by the
eigenvector pi, followed by
little r prime zeroes here,
this has to be a left
eigenvector of t.
So this tells you something
about whether you're going to
have a Jordan form or not,
one of these really
ugly things in it.
And it tells you that
in many cases, you
just can't have them.
If you have them, they're
usually tied up with this
matrix here.
OK, so that, I don't know.
Was this useful?
Does this clarify anything?
Or if it doesn't,
it's too bad.
OK.
So now we want to start
talking about rewards.
Some people call these costs.
If you're an optimist,
you call it rewards.
If you're a pessimist,
you call it costs.
They're both the same thing.
If you're dealing with rewards,
you maximize them.
If you're dealing with costs,
you minimize them.
So mathematically, who cares?
OK, so suppose that each state
i of a Markov chain is
associated with a given
reward, or a sub i.
In other words, you think of
this Markov chain, which is
running along.
You go from one state to
another over time.
And while this is happening,
you're pocketing some reward
all the time.
OK.
You invest in a stock.
Strangely enough, these
particular stocks we're
thinking about here I this
Markov property.
Stocks really don't have a
Markov property, but we'll
assume they do.
And since they have this Markov
property, you win for a
while, and you lose
for a while.
You win for a while, you
lose for a while.
But we have something
extra, other than
just the Markov chains.
We can analyze this whole
situation, knowing how Markov
chains behave.
There's not much left besides
that, but there are an
extraordinary number of
applications of this idea, and
dynamic programming
is one of them.
Because that's just one
added extension beyond
this idea of rewards.
OK.
The random variable x of n.
That's a random quantity.
It's the state at time n.
And the random reward of time n
is then the random variable
r of xn that maps xn equals
i into ri for each i.
This is the same idea of taking
one random variable,
which is a function of another
random variable.
The one random variable takes
on the values one up to
capital M.
And then the other random
variable takes on a value
which is determined by the state
that you happen to be
in, which is this
random states.
So specifying our sub i
specifies what the set of
rewards are, what the reward
is in each given state.
Again, we have this awful
problem, which I wish we could
avoid in Markov chains, of using
the same word state to
talk about the set of
different states.
And also to talk about
the random state
at any given time.
But hopefully by now you're
used to that.
In our discussion here, the only
thing we're going to talk
about are expected rewards.
Now, you know that expected
rewards, or expectations are a
little more generally than you
would think they would be,
because you're going to take the
expected value of any sort
of crazy thing.
If you want to talk about any
event, you can take the
indicator function of that
event, and find the expected
value of that indicator
function.
And that's just the probability
of that event.
So by understanding how to deal
with expectations, you
really have the capability
of finding distribution
functions, or anything else
you want to find.
OK.
But anyway, since we're
interested only in expected
rewards, the expected reward at
time n, given that x zero
is i is the expected value of r
of xn given x zero equals i,
which is the sum over j of the
reward you get if you're in
state j at time n times p sub
ij, super n, which we've
talked about ad nauseum for the
last four lectures now.
And this is the probability that
the state at time n is j,
given that the state
at time zero is i.
So you can just automatically
find the expected
value of r of xn.
And it's by that formula.
Now, recall that this quantity
here is not all that simple.
This is the ij element of the
product of the matrix, of the
nth product of the matrix p.
But, so what?
We can at least write a nice
formula for it now.
The expected aggregate reward
over the n steps from m to m
plus n minus 1.
What is m doing in here?
It's just reminding us that
Markov chains are
homogeneous over time.
So, when I talk about the
aggregate reward from time m
the m plus n minus 1, it's the
same as the aggregate reward
from time 0 up to
time n minus 1.
The expected values
are the same.
The actual sample functions
are different.
OK, so if I try to calculate
this aggregate reward
conditional on xm equals i,
mainly conditional on starting
in state i, then this expected
aggregate reward, I use that
as a symbol for it, is the
expected value of r of xm,
given xm equals i.
What is that?
Well, that's ri.
I mean, given that xm
is equal to i, this
isn't random anymore.
It's just the source sub i.
Plus the expected value of r of
xm plus 1, which is the sum
over j, of pij times r sub j.
That's the time m plus 1 given
that you're in state i at time
m, and so forth, up until time
n minus 1, where the expected
reward, then, is
a piece of ij.
Probability of being in state j
at time n minus 1 given that
you started off in state i
at time 0 times r sub j.
And since expectations add, we
have this nice, convenient
formula here.
We're doing something I normally
hate doing, which is
building up a lot of notation,
and then using that notation
to write extremely complicated
formulas in a way that looks
very simple.
And therefore you will get some
sense of what we're doing
is very simple.
These quantities in
here, again, are
not all that simple.
But at least we can write
it in a simple way.
And since we can write it in a
simple way, it turns out we
can do some nice
things with it.
OK.
So where do we go from
all of this?
We have just said that the
expected reward we get,
expected aggregate reward over n
steps, namely from m up to m
plus n minus 1.
We're assuming that if we start
at time m, we pick up a
reward at time n.
I mean, that's just an
arbitrary decision.
We might as well do that,
because otherwise we just have
one more transition matrix
sitting here.
OK, so we start at time m.
We pick up a reward, which
is conditional on the
state we start in.
And then we look at the expected
reward for time m and
time m plus 1, m plus 2,
up to m plus n minus 1.
Since we started at
m, we're picking
up n different rewards.
We have to stop at time
m plus n minus 1.
OK, so that's this expected
aggregate reward.
Why do I care about expected
aggregate reward?
Because the rewards at any time
n are sort of trivial.
What we're are interested
in is how does this
build up over time?
You start to invest
in a stock.
You don't much care what
it's worth at time 10.
You care how it grows.
You care about its value when
you want to sell it, and you
don't know when you're going to
sell it, most of the time.
So you're really interested
in these aggregate
rewards that you.
You'll see when we get to
dynamic programming what
you're interested
in that, also.
OK.
If the Markov chain is an
ergotic unit chain, then
successive terms of this
expression tend to a steady
state gain per step.
In other words, these terms here
, when n gets very large,
if I run this process for very
long time, what happens to p
sub ij to n minus 1?
This tends towards the steady
state vector pi sub j.
And it doesn't matter
where we started.
The only thing of importance
is where we end up.
It doesn't matter how
high this is.
So we have a sum over j, of
pi sub j times r sub j.
After a very long time, the
expected gain per step is just
a sum of pi j times
our r sub j.
That's what's important
after a long time.
And that's independent of
the starting state.
So what we have here is a big,
messy transient, which is a
sum of a whole bunch
of things.
And then eventually it just
settles down, and every extra
step you do, you just pick up
an extra factor of g as an
extra reward.
The reward might, of course, be
negative, like in the stock
market over the last 10 years,
or up until the last year or
so, who was negative
for a long time.
But that doesn't make
any difference.
This is just a number, and
this is independent of
starting state.
And p sub in can be viewed a
transient ni, which is all
this stuff at the beginning.
The sum of all these terms at
the beginning plus something
that settles down over a
long period of time.
How to calculate that transient,
how to combine it
with the steady state gain.
Then those talk a great
deal about that.
What we're trying to do today
is to talk about dynamic
programming without going into
all of this terrible mess
about dealing rewards
words in a very
systematic and simple way.
You can read about that later.
What we're aiming at is to talk
about dynamic programming
a little bit, and then get
off to other things.
OK.
So anyway, we have a transient,
plus we have a
steady state gain.
The transient is important.
And it's particularly important
if g equals zero.
Namely if your average gain per
step is nothing, then what
you're primarily interested in
is how valuable is it to start
in a particular state?
If you start in one state versus
another state, you
might get a great deal of reward
in this one state,
whereas you make a loss
in some other state.
So it's important to know which
state is worth being in.
So that's the next thing
we try to look at.
How does the state
affect things?
This brings us to one example
which is particularly useful.
And along with being a useful
example, well, it's a nice
illustration of Markov
rewards.
It's also something which
you often want to find.
And when we start talking about
renewal processes, you
will find that this idea here
is a nice connection between
Markov chains and
renewal series.
So it's important for a whole
bunch of different reasons.
OK.
Suppose for some arbitrary
unit chain, namely we're
saying one set of recurring
states.
We want to find the expected
number of steps, starting from
a given state i, until
some particular
state 1 is first entered.
So you start at one state.
There's this other state
way over here.
This state is recurrent, so
presumably, eventually you're
going to enter it.
And you want to find out, what's
the expected time that
it takes to get to that
particular state?
OK?
If you're a Ph.D. student, you
have this Markov chain of
doing your research.
And at some point, you're going
to get a Ph.D. So we can
think of this as the first pass
each time to your first
Ph.D. I mean, if you want to
get more Ph.D.'s, fine, but
that's probably a different
Markov chain.
OK.
So anyway, that's the problem
we're trying to solve here.
We can view this problem
as a reward problem.
We have to go through a number
of steps if we want to view it
as a reward problem.
The first one, first step is to
assign one unit of reward
to each successive state until
you enter state 1.
So you're bombing through this
Markov chain, a frog jumping
from lily pad to lily pad.
And finally, the frog
gets to the lily pad
with the food on it.
And the frog wants to know, is
it going to start before he
gets to this lily pad
with the food on it?
So, if we're trying to find
the expected time to get
there, here what we're really
interested in is a cost,
because the frog is in
danger of starving.
Or on the other hand, there
might be a snake lying under
this one lily pad.
And then he's getting a reward
for staying alive.
You can look at these things
whichever way you want to.
OK.
We're going to assign one unit
of reward to successive state
until state 1 is entered.
1 is just an arbitrary state
that we've selected.
That's where the snake is
underneath a lily pad, or
that's where the food is,
or what have you.
Now, there's something
else we have to do.
Because if we're starting out at
some arbitrary state i, and
we're trying to look for the
first time that we enter state
1, what do you do after
you enter state 1?
Well eventually, normally you're
going to go away from
state 1, and you're
going to start
picking up rewards again.
You don't want that to happen.
So you do something we do all
the time when we're dealing
with Markov chains, which is
we start with one Markov
chain, and we say, to solve this
problem I'm interested
in, I've got to change
the Markov chain.
So how are we going
to change it?
We're going to change it to say,
once we get in state 1,
we're going to stay
there forever.
Or in other words, the frog gets
eaten by the snake, and
therefore its remains always
stay at that one lily pad.
So we change the Markov
chain again.
The frog can't jump anymore.
And the way we change it is
to change the transition
probabilities out of state 1
to p sub 1, 1, namely the
probability given you're in
state 1, of going back to
state 1 in the next transition
is equal to 1.
So whenever you get
to state 1, you
just stay there forever.
We're going to say r1 equal to
zero, namely the reward you
get in state 1 will be zero.
So you keep getting rewards
until you go to state 1.
And then when you go to state
1, you don't get any reward.
You don't get any reward from
any time after that.
So in fact, we've converted
the problem.
We've converted the Markov chain
to be able to solve the
problem that we want to solve.
Now, how do we know that we
haven't changed the problem in
some awful way?
I mean, any time you start out
with a Markov chain and you
modify it, and you solve a
problem for the modified
chain, you have to really think
through whether you
changed the problem that
you started to solve.
Well, think of any sample path
which starts in some state i,
which is not equal to 1.
Think of the sample path
as going forever.
In the original Markov chain,
that sample path at some
point, presumably, is going
to get to state 1.
After it gets to state 1, we
don't care what happens,
because we then know how long
it's taken to get to state 1.
And after it gets to state
1, the transition
probabilities change.
We don't care about that.
So for every sample path, the
time that it takes the first
pass each time to state 1 is the
same in the modify chain
as it is in the actual chain.
The transition probabilities are
the same up until the time
when you first get to state 1.
So for first pass each time
problems, it doesn't make any
difference what you do after
you get to state 1.
So to make the problem easy,
we're going to set these
transition probabilities in
state 1 to 1, and we're going
to set the reward
equal to zero.
What do you call a state which
has p sub i, i equal to 1?
You call it a trapping state.
It's a trapping state because
once you get there,
you can't get out.
And since we started out with
a unit chain, and since
presumably state 1 is a
recurrent state in that unit
chain, eventually you're going
to get to state 1.
But once you get there,
you can't get out.
So what you've done is you've
turned the unit chain into
another unit chain where the
recurrent set of states has
only this one state,
state 1 in it.
So it's a trapping state.
Everything eventually
leads to state 1.
All roads lead to Rome, but it's
not obvious that they're
leading to Rome.
And all of these states
eventually lead to state 1,
but not for quite a
while sometimes.
OK.
So the probability of an initial
segment until 1 is
entered is unchanged, and
expected first pass each time
is unchanged.
OK.
A modified Markov chain is now
an ergotic unit chain.
It has a single recurrent
state.
State 1 is a trapping
state, we call it.
ri is equal to 1 for i unequal
to 1, and r1 is equal to zero.
This says that a state 1 is
first entered at time l, and
the aggregate reward from 0 to
n is l for all m greater than
or equal to l.
In other words, after you get
to the trapping state, you
stay there, and you don't
pick up any more
reward from then on.
One of the things that's
maddening about problems like
this, at least that's maddening
for me, because I
can't keep those things
straight, is the difference
between n and n plus 1,
or n and n minus 1.
There's always that strange
thing, we've started at time
m, we get reward at time m.
So if we're looking at m
transitions, as we go from m
the m plus n minus 1.
And that's just life.
If you try to do it in a
different way, you wind up
with a similar problem.
You can't avoid it.
OK, so what we're trying to find
is the expected value of
v sub i of n, and the limit as n
goes to infinity, we'll just
call that v sub i without
the n on it.
And what we want to do is to
calculate this expected time
until we first enter
state one.
We want to calculate that for
all of the other states i.
Well fortunately, there's a
sneaky way to calculate this.
For most of these problems,
there's a sneaky way to
calculate these limits.
And you don't have to worry
about the limit.
So the next thing I'm going to
do is to explain what this
sneaky way is.
You will see the same sneaky
method done about 100 times
from now on until the
end of course.
We use it all the time.
And each time we do it, we'll
get a better sense of what it
really amounts to.
So for each state unequal to
the trapping state, let's
start out by assuming that
we start at time
zero, and state i.
In other words, what this means
is first we're going to
assume that x sub 0 equals
i for some given i.
We're going to go through
whatever we're going to go
through, then we'll go back
and assume that x sub 0 is
some other i.
And we don't have to worry about
that, because i is just
a generic state.
So we'll do it for everything
at once.
There's a unit reward
at time 0.
r sub i is equal to 1.
So we start out at time
zero and state i.
We pick up our reward of 1, and
then we go on from there
to see how much longer it
takes to get to state 1.
In addition to this unit reward
at time zero, which
means it's already taken us one
unit of time to get the
state 1, given that x sub 1
equals j, namely, given that
we go from state i to state j,
the remaining expected reward
is v sub j.
In other words, if it's times
0, I'm in some state i.
Given that I go to some stage
j, the next unit of time,
what's the remaining accepted
expected time they
get to state 1?
The remaining expected time is
just v sub j, because that's
the expected time.
I mean, if v sub j is something
where it's very hard
to get to state 1, then
we really lost out.
If it's something which is
closer to state 1 in some
sense, then we've gained.
But what we wind up with is the
expected time to get to
state 1 from state i is one.
That's the instant reward that
we get, or the instant cost
that we pay, plus each of
the possible states
we might get to.
There's a cost to go, or
reward to go from that
particular j.
So this is the formula
we have to solve.
What's this mean?
It means we have to solve
this formula for all i.
If I solve it for all i, and
I've solved this for all i,
then that's the linear equation
in the variables v
sub 1 up to v linear equations
in i equals 2, up to m.
We also have decided that
v sub 1 is equal to 0.
In other words, if we start out
in state 1, you expect the
time to get to state 1 is 0.
We're already there.
OK.
So we have to solve these
linear equations.
And if your philosophy on
solving linear equations is
that of, I shouldn't say a
computer scientist because I
don't want to indicate that they
are any different from
any of the rest of us, but for
many people, your philosophy
of solving linear equations
is to try to solve it.
If you can't solve it, it
doesn't have any solution.
And if you're happy with
doing that, fine.
Some people would rather spend
10 hours asking whether in
general it has any solution,
rather than spending five
minutes solving it.
So either way, this expected
first passage time, we've just
stated what it is.
Starting in state i, it's 1 plus
the time to go for any
other state you happen
to go to.
If we put this in vector form,
you put things in vector form
because you want to spend two
hours finding the general
solution, rather than five
minutes solving the problem.
If you have 1,000 states, then
it works the other way.
It takes you multiple hours to
work it out by hand, and it
takes you five minutes by
looking at the equation.
So sometimes you win, and
sometimes you lose by looking
at the general solution.
If you look at this as a vector
solution, the vector v
where v1 is equal to zero, and
the other v's are unknowns, is
the vector r, the
vector r is 0.
0 reward in state 1.
Unit reward in all other states,
because we're trying
to get to this end.
And then we have the matrix
here, t times v.
So we want to solve this set of
linear equations, and what
do we know about this set
of linear equations?
We have an ergotic unit chain.
We know that p has
an eigenvalue,
which is equal to 1.
We know that's a simple
eigenvalue.
So that in fact, when we write
v equals r plus pv as zero
equals r plus p minus
i times v.
And we try to ask whether
v has any
solution, what's the answer?
Well, this matrix here has
an eigenvalue of 1.
Since it has an eigenvalue of
one, and since it's a simple
eigenvalue, there's a space of
solutions to this equation.
The space of solutions is the
vector of all ones and the
vector of all anything else.
In other words, it's a vector of
v times any constant alpha.
Now we've stuck this in here,
so now we want to find out
what's the set of
solutions now.
We observe v plus alpha e also
satisfies this equation if we
found another solution.
So if we found a solution, we
have a one dimensional family
of solutions.
Well, since this eigenvalue is a
simple eigenvalue, the space
of vectors for which r is equal
to p minus i times v as
a one dimensional space, and
therefore there has to be a
unique solution to
this question.
OK.
So in fact, in only 15 minutes,
we've solved the
problem in general, so that you
can deal with matrices of
1,000 states, as opposed
to two states.
And you still have
the same answer.
OK.
So this equation has a simple
solution, which says that you
can program your computer to
solve this set of linear
equations, and you're bound
to get an answer.
And the answer will tell you
how long it takes to get to
this particular state.
OK.
Let's go one to aggregate
rewards with a final reward.
Starting to sound like-- yes?
STUDENT: I'm sorry, for the
last example, how are we
guaranteed that it's ergotic?
Like, I possible you enter a
loop somewhere that can never
go to your trapping
state, right?
PROFESSOR: But I can't do that
because there always has to be
a way of getting to the trapping
state, because
there's only one recurrent
state.
All these other states
are transient now.
STUDENT: No, but I mean--
OK, like, let's say you
start off with a
general Markov chain.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I start off with
a general Markov chain?
You're absolutely right.
Then there might be no way of
getting from some starting
state to state 1, and therefore,
the amount of time
that it takes you to get from
that state to the starting
state is going to be infinite.
You can't get there.
So in fact, what you have to do
with a problem like this is
to look at it first, and say,
are you in fact dealing with a
unit chain?
Or do you have multiple
recurrent sets?
If you have multiple recurrent
sets, then the expected time
to get into one of the recurrent
states, starting
from either a transient state,
or from some other recurrent
set is infinite.
I mean, just like this business
we were going through
at the beginning.
What you would like to do is not
have to go through a lot
of calculation when you have, or
a lot of thinking when you
have multiple recurrent
sets of states.
You just know what
happens there.
There's no way to get from this
recurrent set to this
recurrent set.
So that's the end of it.
STUDENT: OK.
So like it works when you have
the unit chain, and then you
choose your trapping state to
be one instance [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
Good.
Now, yes?
STUDENT: The previous equation
is true for any reward.
But it's not necessary--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it is true for
any set of rewards, yes.
Although what the interpretation
would be of any
set of rewards is if you
have to sort that out.
But yes.
For any r that you choose,
there's going to be one unique
solution, so long as one is
actually a trapping state, and
everything else leads to one.
OK, so why do I want to
put a-- ah, good.
STUDENT: I feel like there's a
lot of the rewards that are
designed for it, designed with
respect to being in a
particular state.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
STUDENT: But if the rewards are
actually in transition, so
for example, if you go from i to
j, there are going to be a
different number from j to j.
How do you deal with that?
PROFESSOR: How do I
deal with that?
Well, then let's talk
about that.
And in fact, it's fairly simple
so long as you're only
talking about expected
rewards.
Because if I have a reward
associated with--
if I have a reward rij, which is
the reward for transition i
to j, then if I take the sum of
rij times p summed over j,
what this gives me is the
expected reward associated
with state j, with state i.
Now, you have to be a little bit
careful with this because
before we've been picking up
this reward as soon as we get
to state i, and here suddenly
we have a slightly different
situation where you have a
reward associated with state i
but you don't pick it up
until the next set.
So this is where this problem
of i or i plus 1 comes in.
And you guys can do that much
better than I can, because at
my age I start out with an age
of 60 and an age of 61 is the
same thing.
I mean, these are--
OK.
So anyway, the point of it is,
if you have rewards associated
with transitions you can always
convert that to rewards
associated with states.
Oh, I didn't really
get to this.
What I've been trying to say
now for a while is that
sometimes, for some reason or
other, after you go through
and end steps of this Markov
chain, when you get to the
end, you want to consider some
particularly large reward for
having gotten to the end, or
some particularly large cost
of getting to the end, or
something which depends on the
state that you happen
to be in.
So we will assign some final
reward which in general can be
different from the reward that
we're picking up at each of
the other states.
We're going to do this
in a particular way.
You would think that what we
would want to do is, if we
went through in steps, we would
associate this final
reward with the n-th step.
We're going to do it
a different way.
We're going to go through n
steps, and then the final
reward is what happens on
the state after that.
So we're really turning the
problem of looking at n steps
into a problem of looking
at n plus 1 steps.
Why do we do that?
Completely arbitrary.
It turns out to be convenient
when we talk about dynamic
programming, and you'll see
why in just a minute.
So this extra final state is
just an arbitrary thing that
you add, and we'll see
the main purpose for
it in just a minute.
OK.
So we're going to now look at
what in principle is a much
more complicated situation than
what we were looking at
before, but you still have this
basic mark off condition
which is making things
simple for you.
So the idea is, you're looking
at a discrete time situation.
Things happen in steps.
There's a finite set of states
which don't change over time.
At each unit of time, you're
going to be in one of the set
of m states, and at each time l,
there's some decision maker
sitting around who looks
at the state that
you're in at time l.
And the decision maker says I
have a choice between what
reward I'm going to pick up
at this time and what the
transition probabilities are for
going to the next state.
OK, so it's kind of a
complicated thing.
It's the same thing that
you face all the time.
I mean, in the stock market for
example, you see that one
stock is doing poorly,
so you have a choice.
Should I sell it, eat my losses,
or should I keep on
going and hope it'll
turnaround?
If you're doing a thesis, you
have the even worse problem.
You go for three months without
getting the result
that you need, and you say,
well, I don't have a thesis.
I can't say something
about this.
Should I go on for one more
month, or should I can it and
go on to another topic?
OK, it's exactly the
same situation.
So this is really a very broad
set of situations.
The only thing that makes it
really different from real
life is this Markov property
sitting there and the fact
that you actually understand
what the rewards are and you
can predict them in advance.
You can't predict what state
you're going to be in, but you
know that if you're in a
particular state, you know
what your choices are in the
future as well as now, and all
you have to do at each unit of
time is to make this choice
between various different
things.
You see an interesting
example of that here.
If you look at this Markov chain
here, it's a two state
Markov chain.
And what's the steady
state probability of
being in state one?
Anybody?
It's a half, yes.
Why is it a half, and
why don't you have
to solve for this?
Why can you look at it
and say it's a half?
Because it's completely
symmetric.
0.99 here, 0.99 here, 0.01
here, 0.01 here.
These rewards here had nothing
to do with the
Markov chain itself.
The Markov chain is symmetric
between states one and two,
and therefore, the steady state
probabilities have to be
one half each.
So here's something where, if
you happen to be in state two,
you're going to stay
there typically
for a very long time.
And while you're studying there
for a very long time,
you're going to be picking up
rewards one unit of reward
every unit of time.
You work for some very stable
employer who pays you very
little, and that's a
situation you have.
You're sitting here, you have
a job but you're not making
much, but still you're making
something, and you have a lot
of job security.
Now, we have a different choice
when we're sitting here
with a job in state two, we can,
for example, you can go
to the cash register and take
all the money out of it and
disappear from the company.
I don't advocate doing
that, except,
it's one of your choices.
So you pick up a big reward of
50, and then for a long period
of time you go back to this
state over here and you make
nothing in reward for a
long period of time
while you're in jail.
And then eventually you pop back
here, and if we assume
the judicial system is such
that it has no memory,
[INAUDIBLE]
you can cut into the cash
register, and, well, OK.
So anyway, this decision two,
you're looking for instant
gratification here.
You're getting a big reward all
at once, but by getting a
big reward with probability
one, you're going back to
state zero.
From state zero, it takes a long
time to get back to the
point where you can get a big
reward again, so you wonder,
is it better to use this policy
or is it better to use
this policy?
Now, there are two basic ways
to look at this problem.
I think it's important to
understand what they are
before we go further.
One of the ways is to say, OK,
let's suppose that I work out
which is the best policy
and I use it forever.
Namely, I use this policy
forever or I
use this policy forever.
And if I use this policy
forever, I can pretty easily
work out what the steady state
probabilities of these two
states are.
I can then work out what my
expected gain is per unit time
and I can compare
this with that.
And who thinks that this is
going to be better than that
and who thinks that this is
going to be better than that?
Well, you can work
it out easily.
It's kind of interesting because
the steady state gain
here and here are very
close to the same.
It turns out that this is just
a smidgen better than this,
only by a very small amount.
OK.
See, what happens here is that
here, you tend to go for about
100 steps here.
So you pick up every reward of
about 100 if you use this very
simple minded analysis.
Then for 100 steps, you're
sitting here, you're getting
no reward, so you think we ought
to get every reward of
one half on the average,
and that's exactly
what you do get here.
And here, you get this big
reward of 50, but then you go
over here and you spend 100
units of time in purgatory and
then you get back again, you get
another reward of 50 and
then spend hundreds units
of time in purgatory.
So again, you're getting pretty
close to a half of a
unit of reward, but it turns
out, when you work it out,
that here is just a smidgen.
It's 1% less than a half, so
this is not as good as that.
But suppose that you have
a shorter time horizon.
Suppose you don't want to wait
for 1,000 steps to see what's
going on, so you don't want
to look at the average.
Suppose this was a
gambling game.
You have your choice of these
two gambling options, and
suppose you're only going to be
playing for a short time.
Suppose you're going
to be only playing
for one unit of time.
You can only play for one unit
of time and then you have to
stop, you have to go home, you
have to go back to work, or
something else.
And you happen to be sitting
in state two.
What do you want to do
if you only have one
unit of time to play.
Well, obviously, you want to get
the reward of 50, because
delayed gratification doesn't
work here, because you don't
get any opportunity for that
gratification later.
So you pick up the big
reward at first.
So when you have this problem of
playing for a finite amount
of time, whatever kind of
situation you're in, what you
would like to do is say, for
this finite amount of time
that I'm going to play, what's
my best strategy then?
Dynamic programming is the
problem, which is the
algorithm which finds out what
the best thing to do is
dynamically.
Namely, if you're going to stop
in 10 steps, stop in 100
steps, stop in one step, it
tells you what to do under all
of those circumstances.
And the stationary policy tells
you what to do if you're
going to play forever.
But in a situation like this
where things happen rather
slowly, it might not be the
relevant thing to deal with.
A lot of the notes deal with
comparing the stationary
policy with this
dynamic policy.
And I'm not going to do that
here because, well, we have
too many other interesting
things that we
want to deal with.
So we're just going to skip
all of that stuff about
stationary policies.
You don't have to bother to
read it unless you're
interested in it.
I mean, if you're interested in
it, by all means, read it.
It's a very interesting topic.
It's not all that interesting
to find out what the best
stationary policy is.
That's kind of simple.
What's the interesting topic
is what's the comparison
between the dynamic policy and
the stationary policy.
But all we're going to do
is worry about what the
dynamic policy is.
That seems like a hard problem,
and someone by the
name of Bellman figured out what
the optimal solution to
that dynamic policy was.
And it turned out to be a
trivially simple algorithm,
and Bellman became
famous forever.
One of the things I want to
point out to you, again, I
keep coming back to this because
you people are just
starting a research career.
Everyone in this class, given
the formulation of this
dynamic programming problem,
could develop and would
develop, I'm pretty sure, the
dynamic programming algorithm.
Developing the algorithm,
understanding what the problem
is is a trivial matter.
Why is Bellman famous?
Because he formulated
the problem.
He said, aha, this dynamic
problem is interesting.
I don't have to go through
the stationary problem.
And in fact, my sense from
reading his book and from
reading things he's written is
that he couldn't have solved
the stationary problem because
he didn't understand
probability that well.
But he did understand how to
formulate what this really
important problem was
and he solved it.
So, all the more credit to him,
but when you're doing
research, the time you spend
on formulating the right
problem is far more important
than the time you spend
solving it.
If you start out with the right
problem, the solution is
trivial and you're all done.
It's hard to formulate the right
problem, and you learn
to formulate the problem not
by playing all of this
calculating things, but by
setting back and thinking
about the problem and trying
to look at things in a more
general way.
So just another plug.
I've been saying this, I will
probably say it every three or
four lectures throughout
the term.
OK.
So let's go back and look
at what the problem is.
We haven't quite formulated
it yet.
We're going to assume this
process of random transitions
combined with decisions based
on the current state.
In other words, in this decision
maker, the decision
maker at each unit of time sees
what state you're in at
this unit of time.
And seeing what state you're in
at this given unit of time,
the decision maker has a choice
between how much reward
is to be taken and along with
how much reward is to be
taken, what the transition
probabilities are
for the next state.
If you rob the cash register,
your transition probabilities
are going to be very different
than if you don't
rob the cash register.
By robbing the cash register,
your transition probabilities
go into a rather high transition
probability that
you're going to be caught.
OK, so you don't want that.
So you can't avoid the problem
of having the rewards at a
given time locked into what the
transition probabilities
are for going to the next state,
and that's the essence
of this problem.
OK.
So, the decision maker observers
the state and
chooses one of a finite
set of alternatives.
Each alternative consists of
recurrent reward which we'll
call r sub j of k, the
alternative is k, and a set of
transition probabilities.
pjl of k, one less than or
equal to a l less than or
equal to m for going
to the next state.
OK, the notation here is
horrifying, but the idea is
very simple.
I mean, once you get used to the
notation, there's nothing
complicated here at all.
OK, so in this example here,
well, we already
talked about that.
We're going to start
out at time m.
We're going to make a decision
at time m, pick up the
associated reward for that
decision, and pick the
transition probabilities that
we're going to use at that
time m, and then go on
to the next state.
We're going to continue doing
this until time m
plus n minus 1.
Mainly, we're going to do this
for n steps of time.
After the n-th decision--
you make the n-th decision
at m plus n minus t--
there's a final transition
based on that decision.
The final transition is based
on that decision, but the
final reward is fixed
ahead of time.
You know what the final reward
is going to be, which happens
at time m plus n.
So the things which are variable
is how much reward do
you get at each of these first
n time units, and what
probabilities you choose for
going through the next state.
Is this still a Markov chain?
Is this still Markov?
You can talk about this
for a long time.
You can think about it for
a long time because this
decision maker might or
might not be Markov.
What is Markov is the transition
probabilities that
are taking place in
each unit of time.
After I make a decision, the
transition probabilities are
fixed for that decision and
that initial state and had
nothing to do with the decisions
that had been made
before that or the states you've
been in before that.
The Markov condition says that
what happens in the next unit
of time is a function simply
of those transition
probabilities that
had been chosen.
We will see that when we look at
the algorithm, and then you
can sort out for yourselves
whether there's something
dishonest here or not.
Turns out there isn't, but to
Bellman's credit he did sort
out correctly that this worked,
and many people for a
long time did not
think it worked.
So the objective of dynamic
programming is both to
determine the optimal decision
at each time and to determine
the expected reward for each
starting state and for each
number and steps.
As one might suspect, now here's
the first thing that
Bellman did.
He said, here, I have
this problem.
I want to find out what happens
after 1,000 steps.
How do I solve the problem?
Well, anybody with any sense
will tell you don't solve the
problem with 1,000
steps first.
Solve the problem with one step
first, and then see if
you find out anything from it
and then maybe you can solve
the problem with two steps and
then maybe something nice will
happen, or maybe it won't.
When we do this, it'll turn
out that what we're really
doing is we're starting at the
end and working our way back,
and this algorithm is due to
Richard Bellman, as I said.
And he was the one who sorted
out how it worked.
So what is the algorithm?
We're going to start out making
a decision at time 1.
So we're going to
start at time n.
We're going to start
in a given state i.
You make a decision, decision
k at time m.
This provides a reward at time
m, and the selected transition
probabilities lead to a
final expected reward.
These are these final rewards
which occur at time n plus 1.
It's nice to have that n because
it's what let's us
generalize the problem.
So this was another clever
thing that went on here.
So the expected optimal
aggregate reward for a one
step problem is the sum of the
reward that you get at time m
plus this final reward you get
at time n plus 1, and you're
maximizing over the different
policies you have
available to you.
So it looks like a trivial
problem, but the optimal
reward with a one step
problem is just this.
OK, next you want to consider
the two step problem.
What's the maximum expected
reward starting at xm equals i
with decisions at times
m and n plus 1.
You make two decisions.
Now, before, we just made
one decision at time m.
Now we make a decision at time
m and at time n plus 1, and
finally we pick up a final
reward at time n plus 2.
Knowing what that final reward
is going to be is going to
affect the decision you make at
time n plus 1, but it's a
fixed reward which is a
function of the state.
You can adjust the transition
probabilities of getting to
those different rewards.
The key to dynamic programming
is an optimal decision at time
n plus 1 can be selected based
only on the state j
at time n plus 1.
This decision, given that you're
in state j at time n
plus 1, is optimal independent
of what you did before that,
which is why we're starting
out looking at what we're
going to do with time n plus 1
before we even worry about
what we're going to
do with time n.
So, whatever decision you made
at time n, you observe what
state you're at time n plus
1 and the maximal expected
reward over times n plus 1 and
n plus 2, given that you
happen to be in state j is just
maximal over k as the
reward you're going to get by
choosing policy k and the
expected value of the final
reward you get if you're using
this policy k.
This is just dj* of 1 and
u as you just found.
In other words, you have the
same situation at time n plus
1 as you have at time n.
Well, surprisingly, you've just
solved the whole problem.
So we've seen that what we
should do at time n plus 1 is
do this maximization.
So the optimal reward, aggregate
reward over times m,
n plus 1, and n plus 2 is what
we get maximizing over our
choice at time m of the reward
we get at time m plus the
decision plus the transition
probabilities which we've
decided on which get us to this
reward at time n plus 1
and n plus 2.
We found out what the reward
is for times n plus 1 and n
plus 2 together.
That's the reward to go, And
we know what that is, so we
have this same formula
we used before.
Why do we want to look at
these final rewards now?
Well, you can view this as a
final reward in state m.
It's the final reward which
tells you what you get both
from state n plus
1 and n plus 2.
And, going quickly, if we look
at playing this game for three
steps, the optimal reward for
the three step game is the
immediate reward optimized over
k plus the rewards at n
plus 1, n plus 2, and n plus 3,
which we've already found.
And in general, the optimal
reward at time n--
when you play the game for n
steps, the optimal reward is
maximum here.
So, all you do in the algorithm
is, for each value
of n when you start with n
equal to 1, you solve the
problem for all states and you
maximize over all policies you
have a choice over, and then you
go on to the next larger
value of n, you solve the
problem for all states and you
keep on going.
If you don't have many
states, it's easy.
If you have 100,000 states, it's
kind of tedious to run
the algorithm.
Today it's not bad, but today
we look at problems with
millions and millions of states
or billions of states,
and no matter how fast
computation gets, the
ingenuity people to invent
harder problems always makes
it hard to solve
these problems.
So anyway, that's the dynamic
programming algorithm.
And next time, we're going to
start on renewal processes.